Alec Baldwin has officially been charged
with involuntary manslaughter in the
deadly shooting on the set of that
western movie rust a weapons specialist
was also charged new documents filed
yesterday allege there were more than a
dozen safety violations in the hours
leading up to the death of Cinema
photographer Helena Hutchins that was
back in 2021 our Chris Van Cleave takes
a look through the charges
the newly released charging documents
accused some on the movie Set rust of
operating with what prosecutors called a
pattern of criminal disregard for safety
justifying the involuntary manslaughter
charges I turned that I went like this
to stay in the camp and she was there
and the gun went off the court documents
allege Alec Baldwin missed required
firearms training before filming began
and when given his own session onset was
distracted by talking on his cell phone
to his family during the training
okay prosecutors say images from the
moments leading up to the shooting that
killed cinematographer Helena Hutchins
show Baldwin's finger on the trigger
Baldwin denied pulling the trigger to
ABC News no no no no no no I would never
point a gun at anyone and pull a trigger
at them never but an FBI forensic review
cited in the formal charges found the
trigger had to be pulled for the gun to
fire I'm the armor armor or Hannah
Gutierrez Reid oversaw the weapons on
set she also faces involuntary
manslaughter charges prosecutors say
Gutierrez Reid did not do standard
safety protocols by failing to show
Baldwin there were no live rounds in the
firearm and by leaving the church set
while he was using the weapon in close
proximity to the cast and crew Gutierrez
reads attorneys called the charges a
complete misunderstanding of the facts
Baldwin's lawyers called him a terrible
miscarriage of Justice this hits home
for Alec Baldwin indeed he is facing
real legal Jeopardy CBS News legal
analyst Ricky cleeman says Baldwin faces
two alternative charges of involuntary
manslaughter one could carry a maximum
of 18 months in jail while the other
could carry a mandatory minimum of five
years in prison that's one Mighty roll
of the dice if you go to trial if the
cases go to trial and the jury convicts
either defendant they will decide which
charge applies a judge will now decide
if their sufficient evidence to proceed
for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave in
Los Angeles